all right hello everybody and welcome to
today's live broadcast we're talking on
topic of rapid PGs workflow using an NGS
sequencing and two speakers today are
dr. Fabian mera da and dr. Luiz Alcaraz
I'm Colin Davidson with thermo Fisher
Scientific and I'll be your moderator
for today's event before we begin I'd
like to remind everybody this is an
interactive event and we encourage you
to participate by submitting as many
questions as you would like at the time
you want during the presentation all you
have to do is click the green
question-and-answer button located in
the lower left part of the presentation
window and type the question into the
box that appears on the screen well
answer as many questions that we have
time for at the end of the today's
presentations also please note that you
will be reviewing the presentation in
the slide window to enlarge the window
just click on the screen icon located on
the lower right if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
please click the support button on the
top right of the presentation window or
use the Q&A button to let us know that
you're having a problem I'd like to to
introduce our two speakers Fabian will
be our first speaker he graduated as a
biologist at the University of Lausanne
in 2002 he then obtained his PhD in 2006
after which he joined the human genetics
unit at the MRC in Edinburgh where his
rigors reach research focus was on the
genetics of embryonic development in
2007 he joined the lab laboratory of
reproductive biology for the center of
medically assisted procreation at which
he acquired his s3 certification as a
clinical embryologist in 2010 since 2013
he is responsible for in vitro
fertilization lab of fribourg
switzerland and dr. museu is also the
scientific director of the first
laboratory since 2011 our second
presenter is Luis he's a technical
manager and co-founder of
a bio array he developed his scientific
career in many different fields related
to molecular biology from gene
sequencing to drug discovery but always
with the strong interest in
bioinformatics he obtained his PhD
proteomics during his postdoc he changed
the course of his research to develop
biosensors working on a project to
detect biomarkers in culture media of
human embryos related to aneuploidy
at this time he funded a bio ray with
under his son Tom and from this moment
release has been working passionately
towards playing microarrays and
next-generation sequencing to genetic
diagnosis and with that I'll turn over
the control the audio control to our
first speaker Fabio
so good morning everyone so switch to my
presentation so as Colleen Coakley
introduced an embryologist not a
geneticist and I will present you some
of our recent work on pre-implantation
analysis as to say that in Switzerland
the law has changed very recently last
year PGD and PGs were forbidden and
since few months we are allowed to
propose PGD and PDF to our patients and
linked to this big change in our country
we have developed some some program of
analogies in order to implement it so if
we go back to the history of
pre-implantation genetic screening in
the early days it was done by feast or
fluorescent in situ hybridisation
unclear htlm embryo and at that time the
number of chromosomes that could be
analyzed was limited due to the
techniques there have been other
technical issues such as cell fixation
problems and the specificity of the fish
probes was well not that I at around 89%
and they have discovered at that time
that embryo at eight cell stage is a
limas ayuk
which mean not all cells at the same
chromosomal contents another discovery
that was made at that time is that
embryo biopsy on the three embryo or
eight-cell embryo impacts the embryo
survival and the outcome which mean if
we do genetic analysis of embryo does it
does it improve the chance of pregnancy
during an IVF cycles and in this
Cochrane review they have shown that it
was it was better not to do PGs on
cleavage stage embryo because the damage
you do to the embryo was worse
than the benefit of the genetic analysis
so it was somehow disappointing results
for the early stage of of pgf and then
came out more advanced techniques which
allows to analyze not only a few
chromosomes but the wall chromosomal
contents of a few cells all 24
chromosomes and they have been several
publications showing that it was
feasible to do a comprehensive analysis
on early embryo and it was also shown
that that fish previous fish analogies
were not really reliable then another
revolution came out in our field which
was doing the biopsy not anymore
at day three without d5 so at the
blastocyst stage and the reason why it's
some more revolution first it's because
it's safer for the embryo as you can see
on the right side on that graph we have
compared here it's a it's a cleavage
stage embryo biopsy and here you see the
blastocyst biopsy and as you can see
when doing a biopsy at the three embryo
the implantation is decrease which means
the biopsy emperor's embryo development
whereas when the biopsy is done at the
blastocyst stage it's it's very similar
which means it's not harmful for the
embryo or or rally our armful here are
the benefit of doing blastocyst biopsy
is that you get more cells for genetic
analysis not only one or two but fact
themselves which means much more
accurate results it's also a cost
efficient strategy because you need to
analyze less embryo but it's it's
well-known that more or less as alpha
the embryo will not develop to the
blastocyst stage
I mean some of them we will naturally
arrest in the development which means
the one you need to analyze it is much
lower and as you can see on this graph
you have twice more the three embryo
compared to blastocyst and this is even
at lower number when the maternal age
increase an hour the target patient are
around that area which mean you have
like four or five a blastocyst to
analyze instead of eight ten day three
embryo so it's it's twice last genetic
analysis we could say on average another
revolution was the vitrification of
blastocyst which needs enough time to to
do the genetic analysis so in this
publication this revolution which is a
combination of comprehensive all whoa
chromosome analysis unbiased blastocyst
biopsy was named
PGs 2.0 and at that time one years ago
to have seen as a future of us of PDS
and it has been say that all the
previous results coming from fish
analysis should be forgotten and we are
entering into a new area that is
entirely different from the previous one
and these are the outcomes I have taken
to prospective randomized trial here and
as you can see on the left side in this
studies they have compared untested to
blastocyst transfer which is in yellow
hiren and here we have computed to a
single euploid blastocyst transfer the
blue blocks and as you can see when
applying pgs to to in that situation you
have you have
at least the same pregnancy rates are
transferring to blastocyst without theft
so this mean without any reduction in
efficiency in term of clinical pregnancy
you were able to avoid adding a twins
and the other study by Scott at all on
the right side they have shown that the
implantation rate was improved by PGS
2.0 but then come out another issue
which was not visible ah not that well
known before is that embryo can be
mosaic which mean not all south of the
embryo has the same chromosomal contents
some cells which are underrepresented in
in in yellow such as here as abnormal
chromosomal contents
either chromosome in excess of
chromosome missing whereas other parts
of the embryo like here have a normal
chromosome all contents so depending on
where you do the biopsy
you might end up if you do the biopsy
here you might end up with a fully
normal embryo did she do the biopsy here
you might end up with mixtures of self
normal and abnormal cells and this is
well seen on the graph here during the
analysis where you see here that there
is a mixtures of normal and abnormal
cells this would be fully abnormal so
one chromosome missing this would be 2
copies of the chromosomes and this would
be 3 copies of the chromosomes and in
that case it's in between which means
they are some cells that have one copies
and some cells that have two copies this
is easy visible this is this means that
it's around 50% of ourselves that are
abnormal
whereas on the bottom here you see it's
it's not that that clearly visible it's
most likely that only 20% of the cells
are abnormal so this is some of an issue
depending on why you do your biopsy the
advantage of doing a blastocyst biopsy
as shown here is that as you have more
self of the analysis you have also more
accurate results and you are most likely
to detect mosaicism so a big question
when scientists have discovered that
mosaicism in embryo is quite common is
if it is it all frequent it is and if
you read the literature there are many
differences and many discrepancies there
there they have seen from 10 to 90
percent mosaicism in day 3 cleavage
stage human embryo and the mosaicism
blastocyst has been shown to be present
in five to fifty percent in blastocyst
so as you can see the viability is quite
high and and some some explanation of
why those differences between the
different duplication could be linked to
technical aspect nomber of chromosome
analyzed techniques used could be also
linked to classification criteria what
is defined as mosaic or not it could be
also linked to the the patient group
analyzed in a study for depending on the
stimulation protocol of has been shown
that some stimulation protocol might or
some cultural condition may affect the
percentage of ICS and also the type of
samples that have been used for the for
the research project is it a rested
embryo is it donated debris from egg
donors or it depends on publication to
publication and then it also depends on
the analysis method some of them are
more accurate to detect mosaicism so
then then come out a new revelation for
for PGS which is next-generation
sequencing which has been shown to to be
at least as efficient as a receipt h2
detect and to quantify the number of
chromosome in a pre-implantation samples
and in in that study they have shown
that the implantation rate is almost
doubled when comparing to the control
groups which mean it's it's physical and
efficient to screen for an authority in
embryo using NGS and one big advantage
of NGS compared to the more conventional
array CGH method is that the dynamic
range of NGS is much higher compared to
array CGH as you can see here this is
ready gh results you see that there is
an extra chromosomes but the dynamic
range is much higher in in using
next-generation sequencing and in that
case it's a trisomy of the chromosome 7
which is clearly visible sure she's also
visible here on the array CGH but to a
lower extent because the noise is taking
is getting quite big then if you look at
MOSI example so in that case there is
also a noise Isis for chromosome 12 as
shown here by next-generation sequencing
analysis whether around 50 percent of
the cells that have an extra chromosome
12 if you look at resi gh data it's much
less visible it's very close to the
noise so it's difficult to say whether
it's noisy or whether it's massages so
this one this is one big advantage of
NGS analysis it's it allows a broader
range of analysis and it allows to seem
Musashi's much better so I think we are
entering into a new area of of PDS which
we could film PG ES 3.0
and this has a couple of room eyes first
it allows an accurate detection and
quantification of mosaicism even at at
low amount of mosaicism
it also allows to detect not only full
chromosome and epilady but also if some
part of the chromosome is missing or
part of the chromosome is duplicated
what to be called segmental aneuploidy
and even it allows you to identify the
combination of both which is mosaic
segmental analogy and it has a promise
of lower cost they are still some open
technical question what is the limit on
the accuracy of detection or all down to
the percentage of Malaysia's can we go
are we able to detect small deletion or
small duplication and what are what
about the multiplexing capacity are we
able to to analyze human seeming that'll
easily many samples and there is on all
that question we before we when we
decided to start with our PGS program we
we have done some preliminary studies
which I will show you right now so
basically the technical procedure is
this one so you start with the embryo
biopsy of the trophectoderm at the five
and you get around five to ten cells
then you do whole genome amplification
to massively amplify the the amount of
DNA UF and then you submit this
amplified DNA to the next generation
sequencing this allows you to generate
or to sequence many different very small
sequence thousands of small sequence
from your pre imputation samples and
then with the miracle of of
bioinformatics the system is able to
align all these small sequence to the
recent genome and by counting the number
of
of each small sequence you are able to
quantify the number of chromosomes you
have in your sample and as you can see
her for this chromosome they are not
enough sequence compared to what is
expected which means it's a monosomy for
these chromosomes so we have we have
compared different methods and then
decided to go for the repo sector pges
kids run on the s5 systems and as you
can see her some of the big advantage of
the technique is that it's it's fully
standardized ready to use kits which is
a huge huge option of automation of the
procedures together with options who
have different size of sequencing chip
16 sample 24 samples up to 96 samples so
it adds flexibility and atomization
which we have seen as a big advantage
and then on the top of that there is a
throwing bioinformatic program which
allows to detect mosaicism
and to add some some options such as
gender masking because it's at least in
Switzerland it's it's banned to discard
the embryo gender and it's quite quick
everything in our end could be run in
less than 12 hour even if we had some
optional controls quality controls so
this is our study design
so we had three type of sample for our
tests we have been using cell lines
which are economically well
characterized with deletion and
application we also have used our own
prenatal samples so from patient doing
prenatal even analogies in our genetic
lads these are those for
and with with the cell and variables
also created artificial mosaic samples
by mixing those sample or those samples
to generate artificial mosaic and we
have access to a few but some definitely
arrested embryos limitations and these
are some of the results we get so maybe
let's start first by explaining you what
what you have to look at and what those
graphic are so on the bottom you have
stacks starting here you have all the
chromosomes in a row so this is
chromosome 1 down to chromosome Y here
so you have all from Adam that are
lining on a button and here on the right
you have the copy numbers so in the
middle here adds two copies of the
chromosomes here at one copy and here
it's three copies so as you can see in
this sample for all chromosome starting
from one you have two copies with only
one exception which is here where you
have one copies because it's male male
embryo or male cell lines with one copy
of the X and one copy of the Y so in
this first study what we have done is we
have run 96 sample together and we would
like to check whether it was feasible to
see unafraid of a small chromosomes so
it was chromosome 21 trisomy 21 and you
as you can see here here we are able to
see trisomy from the DNA equivalent of
one self and this is also it works very
well for five cells themselves and 20
cells
so we were really reassured by doing
that which means given when you
analyzing 96 sample in parallel it's
feasible to see a trisomy 21 at the
concentration corresponding to any one
cells then the next task we have done is
to see whether we are able to see sir
chromosomal deletion or duplication so
in that case we analyzed 24 sample at
the same time on the smaller chip and we
were happy to be able to see ten
Megabass deletion in chromosome 2 which
is shown here and will also appears to
be able to see 21 Megabass a chromosomal
duplication and we are at the equivalent
of 2 to 3 cells DN amounts for both
which means this technique allows to see
supra Mazama deletion and application
very accurately and as you can see there
is almost no noise then the question was
is it feasible to see the Nisshin or
duplication when analyzing more sample
together and that gives its 96 sample
analyzed together and as you can see
even at the equivalent of one cells the
deletion is is well visible here which
works as well when you get you have more
more amounts of DNA
so even when analyzing
96 sample together the detection
efficiency remains excellent then we try
to analyze whether with this technology
it's feasible to analyze mosaic samples
so in that case we have done a mixtures
of cell lines which carries one x copy
and to took a piece of the X for the
other Pods so this is what you see her
so in that case it's at
0% miss Isis and then we we go up 20 40
and and up to a key and as you can see
here you can see the mutha he's freezing
with a very competent adaptive manner so
you see that the shift between the two
copies line and and the analysis is
pretty linear compared to the percentage
of maliciousness and it that gave it it
is still 26 samples and allied together
with a DNA amount of 5 cells which mean
for 20% it means only one one self
different from the others so it means
that you I but if you have 5 cells you
are able to see a discrepancy with in
only one cells then the last challenge
was to to bring put everything together
whether it's feasible to analyze
mosaicism which is segmental so moses'
small only part of a chromosome is
missing and we are some more pushing the
techniques at its limits so we keep
analyzing nineties example and as you
can see here it's it's feasible to see
segmental mosaic and a ploy Diaz front
here and here so this was our last
experiment and we decided to push the
system to to its limit and it's still
quite good in terms of results then we
have run a couple of real samples which
are arrested embryos that have been
donated by the patient which means that
these are embryos that did not did not
go to the blastocyst stage which so we
do not implant that as
as they were planned do the analysis
with the agreement of the patient we
have done some analysis it also Excel to
replace a patient to understand why the
embryo arrested then that gives in this
example it's a monogamy of the
chromosome to our insurer and in that
case it was an embryo that didn't do any
compaction so it even do not go to the
maha stage so we split it in two parts
and analyze the two part separately from
the same embryo and as you can see it's
a monosomy of the chromosome 22 after
ensure and we get the same results for
the 7 alpha d mu which was reassuring
so then regarding to the power of such a
method it comes from some biological
question we are able to see many things
in the other embryo we are able to see
messiahís we are able to see silk
emotional defects or should we deal with
that and what what shall we do with that
it had been shown in some publications
that mosaic embryo can implant even if
the pregnancy rates are much lower but
it's not zero and some some mosaic
embryo are able to give rise to healthy
baby this could be due to two
discrepancy between the placenta and the
fetus itself as we are analyzing
perfecter themselves so not the cells
that would form the future features but
we are on onion writing the cells that
will form the placenta there could be a
discrepancy were membrillo is is
diagnosed abnormal where it's normal and
it also also be mentioned that even it
was more in the 3 MB you that there are
some risk
miscue possible which means some of the
abnormal cells can be removed by the
embryo I have to say that all all those
things are quite rare event so that
often that an embryo is best killed or
that they are feet
discrepancy but it's good to know that
it could happen so for my last slide of
conclusion I think we are entering into
a new area of PGS we are now able to
detect segmental aneuploidy and we are
now able to detect low level of noise
Isis the question remains shall we go to
higher resolution in order to see more
or should we do the resolution in order
to do more at the same time and thus we
discussed for the patient so it also
always a discussion between quest and
resolution and maybe the solution is as
some more more customized for some
patients the resolution is important
some sometimes they might be carrier of
deletion or duplication that is quite
small or you need to look for other
things and in other case it's also
important to look at the cost so
altogether it means that we have we get
more information from our samples but it
means also very high complexity for the
interpretation and we are lucky to be
helped by some excellent guidelines one
from the crow gene and one from the PGD
is where you can find many
recommendation in particular on which
mosaic embryo are suitable for transfer
and which one are dangerous to transfer
so any and they are quite often revised
but the main conclusion would be that I
think all those information should be
well discussed together with the patient
first in preparation so before we do the
analysis but also after as soon as we
have the result because this is a final
decision has to be taken by the patient
and and we are here to add them but we
are not here to decide for them and that
from a LifeFlight I would like to thank
people involved in the world so there
were people from our Center for
Reproductive Medicine in
in Switzerland at cpma and then and then
also fast Aires which is our sequencing
laboratory together with our partner and
Cl our genetic laboratory thanks as well
to demo Fischer for the for the
collaboration and I needed to call in
for the next speaker yeah thanks so much
Fabian so we can now transition to Luis
and his presentation on PGS PDD combined
okay so thank you Colleen thank you to
all of you for being here my name is
Michael I'm technical manager by alright
which is a genetic lab look at it in the
southwest of Spain here in my company we
do almost everything in genetic analysis
through the leading technologies such as
micro eyes and next-generation
sequencing applied to prenatal postnatal
are implantation on genetic diagnosis
everything using a variety of platforms
and so probably you are known that in
genetics we are living our golden age
technologies are evolving incredibly
fast especially in the field of
next-generation sequencing we are living
a situation similar to the computer
revolution in the eighties to such an
extent that if you want to have in your
lab the latest NGS technology you must
change your sequence in your sequencer
more often than you more money pot but
fortunately this is not always necessary
as you will see in the following slide
you can do very nice things with simpler
sequences anyway now it is possible to
adapt almost any genetic test to
next-generation sequencing as we did for
PTT and pts few years ago we started
this evolution more around three years
ago first for pts with a protocol
developed by our service
now using iron Reaper stick and at the
same time with we made this evolution
also for for PT d for monogenic
disorders and more important we were
able to join both protocols on the dole
and to do both things at the same time
well I think we are probably the the
first lab in the water doing everything
reproductive genetics with
next-generation sequencing it doesn't
matter if we are talking about PG d PG s
application majnu monogenic diseases or
they die ups in the three-day fight with
fresh or frozen cycles we always run
next-generation sequencing so why we
decided to establish movement despite
the been difficult I used to say that
the fidgety lobbies is very complex if
you want to do a PDS you need to set up
a lab equip and designed to do microwave
including a microwave Shannon and
hybridization oven then if you want to
do monogenic disorders you need first
Sanger sequencing and which included a
capillary sequence that is most
expensive that so many genes machines
and also some equipment to do from an
analysis because you need to run then
form a DVD test and indirect testing
like for example an electro phoretic
system and finally if you want to use
carry mapping then you need a older
microarray scanner but you know bad luck
because it's differently from the
scanner use it for for our CGS so at the
end you need a lab that is similar to
this with a lot of equipment and a lot
of people working at the same time with
the same samples all of them well
coordinated by my lab manager because
you know we need to to fine-tune on the
experiments especially when working a
day three with fresh transfer
and you know this is a as you can see
this is this is very nice it is
wonderful but the problem is that is is
very expensive
however next-generation sequencing has
been game-changing technique
next-generation sequencing is like
one-man band
NGS means choral action the possibility
of analyzing very challenging samples to
combine different analysis everything
faster and we send equipment that can be
managed by one person without much
stress and for this reason in the recent
years we are trying to do everything
with Indians as you will see with 10
years we are able to do a nobody testing
for PCs aspirin has shown the analysis
of point mutation for PGD and the
analysis of polymorphisms for the
indirect test well for for pts for
elevated screening we were lying in I
are a perfect solution I'm not going to
talk about it because you have seen a
very nice presentation from Fabian we
use the system because it's fast robust
and cost-effective but what about
monogenic disorders in monogenic the
service this is the most common
situation usually we have we have a
couple usually we have a couple in which
both are healthy carriers of a recessive
disorder this couple is at risk or
having a child a affected by by this
disorder very often the couple already
have a child with the disease and they
want to avoid the possibility of having
another one for this reason they go to
two one IVF centers to perform a PT
recycle to select the embryo without at
least one of the of the mutations as you
know
performing PDT in a in a classical way
requires to combine several techniques
like mini sequencing
fragment analysis we use the first one
to directed the mutation of interest but
but we need also to use an indirect test
to confirm the results and exclude
something that is called a little drop
out by analyzing several polymorphisms
around the mutation of interest so the
direct test is is easy with a sequence
the mutation of interest so imagine that
these are the ritual ends of a gem that
you want to sequence and in red we have
the mutation we are interested in
usually after PCR we have similar copies
of both alleles and when we sequence we
can see the mutation by this way because
we can see a mix of two peaks so
according to this result we can classify
this embryo as a career of the mutation
so that's easy but very often around in
five percent of the cases we have a
phenomenon called
a low dropout this is caused by a
technical artifact in which during the
PCR only 1/ln is amplified and the other
one is missed so when we sequence we get
the results from just one Annelle in
that case for example the healthy ll the
problem here is that if we look at this
result we may think that this is a
healthy embryo and suitable for transfer
which is obviously a misdiagnosis so how
can we be confident in our souls so to
be confident with the indirect test for
the intellectus what we do is to look
around the mutation we are interested in
to find a polymorphism that can help us
to to confirm the result
so here for example we have our
chromosomes and here the mutation we are
analyzing what we do is to look around
the mutation for a special type of
polymorphisms that are called shorten
and repeat in in SDS we have a short
sequence that can be repeated several
times and the capo here is that any of
us have a different number of
repetitions so by analyzing the decouple
and over affected family members we are
able to know which polymorphisms are
shared between all the affected family
members so if we don't see the mutation
of interest never any polymorphisms
share with affected family members we
can be confident in our results so for
this reason this classical way of doing
P TV is expensive and annoying for the
couple because usually when it samples
from from other family members in order
to complete them from activity tests and
this requires time and money a marvel
usually couples don't combine PT and PTT
because this increases the price quite a
lot since we need to combine different
techniques so for the duration of the
working for awhile with with pts and we
decided to try to do also the study of
monogenic disorders so when we decided
to make this movement 20 years in the
market there were a couple of platforms
offering bench up sequencer at this
point we decided to go for the Ion
Torrent machine for for this reason the
first one is that is fast since it is
possible to complete more than a run in
a day
the second one is that is flexible
because you can use three different
types of chips with different throughput
so we can purchase few or many samples
without affecting so much the price
finally this technique is is very cost
effective so we enter yes the the direct
path is is so with India the negative
this is easy we just need to sequence
the region we want to analyze here for
example you have an example this
coupling which he is his career of a
point mutation in the nf2 gene which is
responsible of neurofibromatosis type 2
you can see here the mutation and as you
can see there is no mutation in the in
the sample of couple so but the the
inheritance is a little bit more
difficult and it's not possible to use
STL for the analysis because STR are
quite difficult to analyze by NGS for
technical reasons but you know we have
other possibilities so we decided to
analyze several polymorphisms one
megabyte is close to to the mutation but
we users need instead of STR the problem
with has need is that even in 1 min
erase it is possible to find thousand of
his lips but but most of them won't be
informative because both panels will be
homozygous for this polymorphism so the
first challenge is is to select the
snips more likely to be informative
which is not easy but we developed an
algorithm to do this this is quite the
complex and takes into consideration
different things for example the
frequency in the population here for
example you know far graphic in which
you can see the the different
distribution of different a snips
depending on the population of interest
and other thing to consider is their
distribution in up roblox and applause
LOX is a set of a SnipSnap an inherited
together the problem here is that if you
select several his nibs and all of them
belongs to the same upper block this is
this is a waste of time because all of
them we work in the same way so if one
is non informative none will be so at
the end what we do is to select more
than 100 this needs around the mutation
that are more likely to be informative
and to amplify all these snips we use
the the unpleasing technology I think it
is a great tool for this because it's a
highly multiplex PCR with simplistic we
are able to amplify thousand of PCR
products in one single reaction and they
say simplifying the protocol so if we
want to combine PT sm p DD we do a low
coverage sequencing as you have seen in
the in the variant presentation for pts
and for PGP we do an enrichment of the
region of interest with ampliseq
technology which allow us to have high
coverage there the protocol is is also
very very simple first we do the
amplification with the iron Reaper
succeed then we take an eloquent of the
amplified material and we perform the
amplification of the invitation and the
selector snips with a ballistic we put
together both libraries and perform the
been training with with isothermal
method and finally we do the sequencing
with 100 base pair and they
bioinformatic analysis this is the
manual protocol with PCM but it is also
validated with Iron Chef and s54 the
mathematic analysis
we follow two ways first for four pts we
use the iron reported as recommended but
for PTD we follow a custom protocol
which consists first in to perform the
the alignment of the wrist and the man :
with the server provided in the Indian
server and finally we analyze the
sequences to find the mutation of
interest and also they sniff for facing
and this is an example here you have the
same example as as before in which in
which we have a couple with the male
affected by habilitative mutation in the
NFC gene you can see the mutation here
and if we analyze the embryos we found
that embryo number two and number three
are carriers of the mutation and number
one and number four unhealthy however if
we analyze one of the informative his
nibs a close to the mutation we can see
that this snip which considering it with
the healthy ll is present only in the
Brio number one and not in the in the
embryo number four so that means that
embryo number one is really healthy and
in embryo number four we had an allele
dropout and therefore is not really
healthy but how we know that this is
nipkow circuit with the healthy ll we
know these things to to the ethnic
facing and I'm going to show you how it
works
imagine that we
I have a situation in which we have a
couple a career of addresses if we
decide the disease for an ethnic facing
we always need another sample from
another family from another family
member or and in this case a sample from
a previous abortion imagine that these
bars represent a lens from the male
patient this bar from the female and
obviously they indicated we will found
also to our lens one from the father and
another one from the mother the cells
are also negated to the pathogenic
alleles in both parents because they
because the fetus has inherited a both
mutations and what we want to know is
the status of each embryo if they are
healthy or not imagine that we are we
are analyzing one snip and we have this
result the father is a terrorist angles
and the mother is in summer cycles and
the fetus is a shorter cycles obviously
these a must come from the father and
belongs to the pathogenic allel because
this is a little that is shared by both
these t games from the games from the
model and for the same reason and and
also we can analyze the embryos in the
same way now one more here again the the
father is heterozygous but the the photo
system of cycles so again 1 3 is 1 C is
from the father and the other C is from
the is is from the mother and for this
reason this G
it must belong to the healthy ll because
it is not shared with the petals and and
again we analyzed the embryos in a in a
similar way now one more for the mother
here the mother is heterozygous and the
father is ISA messiahs the fetus is is
homozygous so again this G must come
from the father and the G must come from
the mother belongs to the pathogenic ll
because it is share with the mother
again we analyzed embryos and we in the
same way and the last example the father
is messiahs the the model is
interscience and here the fetus is
heterozygous so this c belongs to the
father and this a to the model and again
it is negated to the pathogenic Allah
with it because it is shared between the
mother and the fetus and again we
analyze the embryos so after analyzing
of nips in the photos and in embryos we
have a situation like this and now we
can compare the alert in the embryos and
ll in the independence and the photos
and with this comparison we can know you
can know if they alone are generated by
embryos are healthy or or pathological
so we can now
now if the embryos are affected a
healthy carriers or fully healthy up to
now we were doing this facing manually
for for all the names however we have
developed web platform to do this
automatically here you can upload all
the files from the sequencing
and here you have the response here you
can see the family tree oh and here you
can see there's a sense of of them
breo's I want to stress out that we are
able even to identify a reveal in which
we had a recombination and now briefly I
want to present against a study here we
have a couple which is healthy with two
natural pregnancies and that in 18
induced abortion due to skeletal
dysplasia diagnosis by ultrasound these
couples came to our lab for genetic
counseling but in this case in the tech
counseling was difficult because there
is more than 300 genes related to a
skeletal dysplasia
so we decided to to do exome sequencing
for the couple and also for that one of
the abortions and we discovered two
mutation in this gene which is related
to Jun syndrome so with this information
we were able to to set up we were able
to to to say that repeatedly we were
able to set up a PCV cycle and we
analyzed up to 7 embryos unfortunately
we have to to euploid embryos that were
also a healthy carrier so we have two
embryos to transfer and one worst answer
and far as I know there is an ongoing
pregnancy
so finally we made this in the solution
available to any person interested we
have just launched a kit for PT d that
can be combined with the iron rapper
sick kid
the kit includes all the necessary
things for the study of a monogenic
disorder also access to the online tool
for the for the bioinformatics analysis
so just to sum up this is our
conclusions about using next-generation
sequencing for for PT and pts we found
that the use of NGS is fast and
versatile and scalable since we can
analyze few or many embryos we can
combine pts and PTT in one single test
and even informative tests and finally
it is very cost effective so just to
finish I want to thank some my team for
their hard work developing of the things
thank you all of you for your attention
super well thank you Fabian release for
informative presentations we will now
start with the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just by
clicking the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box and
click send watch there's many we have
time for we're quickly approaching the
hour but let's get started
I said there's some many questions here
I think directed to Fabian on mosaicism
which is obviously a very new and
rapidly developing topics we have Moreno
la Volpe from the genea laboratory and
the question is in your opinion which is
the most important factor that could
increase mosaicism rate in the lab
and so difficult to explain that there
have been some publication showing that
inappropriate culture condition could
could have impact on mosaicism which
mean if the embryo is subjected to some
stress during the the culture it could
it could increase the rate of unemployed
II which means abnormal chromosome
segregation during the first edition and
then chromosome in excess on one side of
the embryo and chromosome missing on the
other side it should be remembered that
early early cleavage embryo do not have
that many genetical checkpoints so it's
able to go further even if it's carrier
of some abnormal chromosomal contents so
if there are some stress on the Meo
during the early cleavage it could be
passed through the next cell generation
okay thank you
the next one also is a similar this one
is on sort of thresholds here for
transfer would you transfer a 20 percent
mosaic or and what about forty sixty
eighty so the sort of clinical
obligation here
yeah so we have made our own own
guidelines based on published one and
now a geneticist will give a different
treatment recommendation depending on
which chromosome is is concerned and
whether it's a trisomy or whether it's
monosomy obviously the one that are I
risk of giving rise to a unhealthy child
such as mosaic trisomy 21 should not be
transfer whereas someone monosomy which
are detailed to the embryo may be at
less risk because the maximum the embryo
should rest but in a old case in our
reproductive centers when we have no
other option for sure we will transfer
further fully LC embryo will also
suggest if there are no normal embryo
with
mosaic one we will soldiers to the
patient if possible to do another IVF
cycles but if the patient would like to
transfer for different reason we refer
them to a genetic counselor to discuss
with the patient about the risk the
consequences and to add them to take
their the decision for that but
basically our recommendation are based
on the type of chromosome involved in
mosaicism and whether it's monogamy
autonomy if I can add something in
general in my lab we do not recommend
the transfer of Maasai cambria the only
recommendation is is fermented when this
is the last chance for the couple but
this is done we always highly recommend
to perform prenatal diagnosis with
microwaves to the 30a any possible
mosaicism in the in the fetus
so I am gonna meet I wanted the limit in
megabases that you've detected for PGS
and in our expert the experience we have
done we go down to 17 that it was the
way the experiment was designed in the
beginning and and it was very accurate
so the question was we did we'd had been
able to go lower than that but we
haven't done that I don't know whether
by were how you have any experience on
that yes usually we are able to detect
aberrations around 10 mega races but it
is true that it depends on the
chromosome affected because there is
some chromosomes that is more easy to
detect the aberrations and other are
more difficult okay so you know skip to
this time let me skip to this last
question here sort of controversial and
the Stars trial was recently released
which so this is this is a question from
the interests at the University of
Zurich is it clear and demonstrated the
PGS can increase pregnancy rates and
take home baby rates that way for both
both are seekers so I think we are as I
mentioned entering in the new area of
PGs it's not that far away that many
PGs well done on day 3 embryo or we're
done with fish or a situation arises so
the question is whether with all those
new technology it will be fully
convincing or whether we have some
disappointment it's too early to say but
I would say the the studies are coming
out very recently are highly positive
and even the most skeptical ones which
have faced the disappointment of the
past might be might be reassured but
would say too early to - definitely if
you say that it's that's the way to go
for for most of the patient I don't know
well in my opinion this is also depends
on on on how you measure the success I
mean if you are taking into account only
the duration of having a baby at home
then this through that maybe pts
increase that's likely the ratio but if
you take into account more more things
like the how many times do you require
to have this baby at home and how many
cycles how many transfers so you taking
talk on all these things when bts's is
definitely good for for for IVF
excellent in the interest of time I
think will answer the remaining
questions via email once again I'd like
to thank our speakers and please note
that the presentations will be available
on-demand viewing through to April 2018
and you'll receive an email from labret
so when this webcast will be available
for replay so with that I'd like to
thank our speakers and for everybody who
could join us today and we hope to see
you again soon thank you very much and
goodbye
thank you